المشاهدين اعود واذكر هذه الصور التي
تشاهدون هي صور خاصه للعربيه من مركز
الزلزال بالتحديد من منطقه دفنه في
انطاكيا مركز ولايه هاتاي وهي مركز
الزلزلين الجديدين الذين هز جنوب تركيا
طبعا
وكذلك مناطق سوريا وحتى في لبنان شعر
السكان بهذه الهزه القويه
مراسلنا هناك في دفنه منذ فتره لا اعلم
اذا كنت
تسمعني زيدان زنكلو
زيدان لا يسمعني ولكن نحن نراقب هذه الصور
هناك جرافات على ما يبدو تتقدم باتجاه
المبنى الذي انهار قبل قليل جراء هذا
الزلزال الجديد
لا نعلم اذا كانت تحاول اخراج شيء ما او
يعني التاكد سنشاهد معكم هذه الصور اذا
جرافه تتقدم
باتجاه هذا المبنى الذي انهار قبل قليل
جراء الزلزال الجديد مركزه اذن انطاكيا
مركز ولايه هاتاي كما نتابع معكم هذه
الصور المباشره فرق افادا تابعه لهيئه
اداره الكوارث والازمات التركيه
هذا المبنى كان شهد اندلاع حريق هناك في
منطقه دفنه
وجرى اخماده قبل قليل اعود اذكر حصيله
الضحايا حتى الان ثلاثه قتلى في تركيا 213
جريحا حتى الان حسب اخر تحديث لوزير
الداخليه التركي سليمان سويلو اما في
الاراضي السوريه فالحصيله 470 مصابا وهناك
عدد كبير كما ذكر مراسلنا قبل قليل المريخ
ادلب من المصابين اصابتهم جراء القاء
انفسهم من الشروفات ومن النوافذ بعد
شعورهم بهذا الزلزال الجديد خوفا طبعا
وهلعا وهربا من هذا الزلزال وانهيار 12
مبنى في مناطق شمال غرب سوريا